more muscle you have the more fat you
burn Christine Cavaliere reveals the
surprising fitness tip that changed her
body your three tips to getting bikini
bod ready I think especially a lot of
girls put so much emphasis on cardio but
for me my body changed when I just gave
up cardio and just started lifting
weights the more muscle you have the
more fat you burn I would say eat as
clean as possible and you've heard it a
million times but drink a ton of water
no soda
stay away from alcohol that's huge when
et caught up with a mom of three at the
relaunch bash for her emeralds of
jewelry line she also set the record
straight on reports she's working on a
cookbook kristin is already the author
of one book balancing in heels
I read that maybe after putting out this
book that you were inspired to put out a
cookbook
yeah just true um I hope so I will see
its hopefully it's gonna happen what
kind of recipes would it be more kid
focused would it be a little bit of
everything or you know I try to be
healthy eighty percent of the time and
then twenty percent I indulge I eat
whatever I want and I enjoy life so I
think most of it would be healthy and
then there would be a few cheat meals
here and there what's your like cheat go
to well when I just gone to eat I'm a
big big pasta girl but carb and sweet
girl um but like my dad's Italian he has
this amazing recipe for meatballs and
you know there's milk and there's all
there's all kinds of white bread and all
that kind of stuff in it but I don't
typically eat but like I would put that
recipe in there and then I wouldn't have
a kids section